The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
We're going to get started.
The homework-- does everybody
have a copy of the handout?
If not, there's some
on the steps there.
There's Muddy
Cards on the steps.
And we're going to do
three things today.
That's this complex
problem I want
to talk about, a problem
on center of percussion.
And then as we have
time, I'm going
to summarize some
summarising statements
about imbalances, which we've
talked a lot about off and on.
So I want you restrain looking
at the notes I've handed out.
The notes I've handed out
are this complex problem.
And I'll let you look
at them in a minute.
But I want to get you to think
about some things before you
see what's on the notes.
But the notes are
intended so that you
don't have to spend a lot of
time writing down messy stuff.
You can think and listen.
And they'll also be
sent out on the web,
posted, so you don't have to
grab a copy for your friends.
Because I only made 100 copies
and there are 122 of you.
OK.
So let's start
with this problem.
This is basically a complex
system, a mass, a pendulum.
And when you-- I've
made up one for you.
So here's the pendulum.
It's on an axle
stuck into my cart.
The cart's got springs
connecting to it.
And it naturally
has some damping.
So this is a realization
of what's been drawn there.
So let's just give
it a little bump.
Cart moves back and forth.
Pendulum swings back and forth.
If I start it this way,
it'll act a lot more crazy.
It'll have a more chaotic
looking kind of motion.
The reason for that
has to do with, this
is a multiple degree
of freedom system, has
more than one natural frequency,
has more than one frequency
that responds, all
mixed together.
And that's why it'll do
kind of crazy things.
Like that'll stop, almost
stop, and then start up again,
stuff like that.
All completely natural.
But if I give it a
nice, gentle start,
it actually mostly
vibrates in what
I call one mode of vibration.
OK?
So we want to get the equations
of motion of this system.
So here, I've drawn it.
And the first question
about a system
like this when you
go to analyze it
is, how many degrees of
freedom does it have.
All right?
So I'm going to claim this to
be a planar motion problem.
It's confined to the board
and confined to rotation
perpendicular to the board.
OK?
Any time that happens,
each object has,
at most, three degrees of
freedom, x y, and a rotation.
So we said no rotations
around x or around y.
So three possible ones for
this mass, three possible ones
for this mass.
And then we start looking for
the constraints in addition.
Well, this one is constrained.
It can't move out
of the-- let's see,
we've already constrained that.
Wait a second.
How do I want to say this?
This one is certainly
constrained in the y because
of the track here.
So that's one constraint.
We're starting off
with six possible.
We've got one because
it's constrained in the y.
But it can certainly
move in the x.
Can it rotate in the
z, this big mass?
So that's two.
So out of the three
possible, the top one only
has one possible
degree of freedom, x.
This one also has three
possible degrees of freedom.
It's pinned at A. What does
that do for constraint?
So this one, take 30 seconds
and talk to your neighbor.
How many constraints are
caused by the pin at A?
All right.
So at least-- how many believe
that there's one constraint
provided by the pin at A?
Let's see the hands that
believe we have one.
Get them up high, up high now.
How about two?
OK.
How about three?
All right.
A little uncertainty here.
Do you know the motion at A?
Have you prescribed the
motion at A in any way?
In what way?
I see you nodding your head.
AUDIENCE: It has to move
with the other block.
PROFESSOR: It has to
move with the block.
But we've already given the
other block a coordinate.
What is it?
AUDIENCE: In x.
PROFESSOR: So if you know x,
do you know the motion of A?
OK.
So you have established
the motion of A.
So if you know A-- you don't
need any additional information
about A do you?
You've already chosen
a coordinate for it.
So if A is
prescribed, that means
x1 and y1, the motion--
the coordinates
describing this
thing-- and I've given
started at a center of
mass, a little x1 that way,
and a little y1 that way.
Those are my possible
displacement coordinates.
And it has a
rotation coordinate.
Three possible degrees
of freedom, right?
x and y are prescribed
at this point.
If you prescribe the
motion-- fix the motion--
at any point on a
rigid body, what
does that say about
translational motion
any place else on
the rigid body?
Remember, this is back
to that subtle definition
of what we mean by translation,
what we mean by rotation.
AUDIENCE: It's a
parallel motion.
PROFESSOR: Parallel motion.
The translation part of this--
every point on the object
moves parallel to
every other point.
So if you've prescribed the
translation of any one point
you have prescribed the
translation for all.
So this second body,
basically, its only translation
that it can have is
x of the main body.
So you have confined
it in x and y.
It has no x and y possibilities.
Those are two constraints
leaving you with-- one.
Right?
One degree of freedom.
And then we pick a
coordinate for it.
And the natural one to use
for that is the angle here.
So we need two.
Two coordinates completely
describe the motion.
It will yield two
equations of motion.
OK?
So on quizzes, you say, how many
independent degrees of freedom
are there.
That is the same
question as saying,
how many equations of motion are
required to completely describe
this system.
Or how many
independent coordinates
are required to completely
describe the motion of system?
They're, all three,
the same questions.
And that threw a couple
people on the last quiz.
OK.
Let's move on to
free body diagrams.
So now we know we've got two
coordinates, theta and x.
And now you're free
to look at your--
you can be free
to look at things.
And I want you to
spend most of your time
thinking and listening
and not having to write.
But make notes as you get
insights about things.
Free body diagram
then, two of them.
The pendulum piece is
actually pretty simple.
You've got Mg down.
And you have two possible forces
at this point of rotation.
And I've just named
them F1 and F2.
And I've drawn them--
not arbitrarily,
but I've picked the
direction to draw them in.
I don't know what
direction they're in.
And that's my complete
free body diagram.
If I've missed
anything, tell me.
Or if you have any
questions about it, ask me.
OK.
The free body diagram
for this guy-- this
is capital M. This one's M1.
This is mass M2 just
to keep it straight.
Lots of possible
forces in this thing.
Reaction forces
through the wheels,
there are only vertical.
I've left out friction,
ignored friction.
But also, these F1
and F2 act at to pin.
And notice I've drawn
them exactly equal
and opposite to these.
Kind of a key thing to do.
And why do we do that?
There's a law.
What's the law?
Newton's third.
You've bot to do that
or else it won't work.
OK?
These are common unknowns.
But they're equal and
opposite at this point.
And we have an M1g hanging down.
The spring force resists.
Any positive motion,
a spring pulls back.
Any positive velocity,
the damper holds back.
And that's all of the
forces on this thing.
It's going to be necessary
to be able to break
these things down.
Because I'm going to sum things.
Going to need to have bits
and pieces of F2 and F1,
so cosine thetas
and sine thetas.
Now resist looking at
your paper for a second.
Next concept question.
We talked a lot
in the last couple
of the lectures about the
best approach to do problems,
right, especially
using angular momentum.
Do you think you're going
to need some angular
momentum to solve this problem?
An approach using torques
and angular momentum?
More than likely.
Anytime things are
rotating, more than likely.
So what's the best
approach here?
Are we going to compute
angular momentum with respect
to A, that pivot point?
With respect to g,
the center of mass?
And it's not too obvious.
So if you were starting
out this problem,
how would you begin it?
Would you decide, I'm going to
sum my torques around point A
or, I'm going to sum
my torques around g?
Did I mark g?
Yeah, it's right at the center.
All right.
Think about that for a second.
Got a question?
All right.
I'm going to ask you this.
Any questions
about the question?
I want a real show
of hands here.
I want you to just-- what
would you do to start with?
So how many would sum torques,
compute angular momentum
with respect to point A?
OK.
How about g?
Hmm, interesting.
And another way?
Some of you are
holding back on me.
Not everybody raised
their hands here.
OK.
All right.
Most people would
do it around A.
A would work.
g would work too.
And in fact, when I sat
down to do this problem,
I did it with A first.
And then I went
and did it with g.
And it turns out that
doing it with respect to g
is just slightly easier.
OK.
So the approach we need to
find two equations of motion.
We have two bodies.
We're going to use Newton's and
Euler's laws to go after them.
So starting out, first
one, sum of the forces
in the x direction on this body.
There's a lot of unknowns.
So I'm going to end
up-- or start off--
with more than two equations.
Because I've got
how many unknowns?
One, two, three, four,
x, the motion x, five,
and the angle theta, six.
I could need as many as six
equations to start with.
If I sum forces in the
vertical direction I can--
it turns out that N1 and N2
two here, I never actually
have to deal with.
So don't start there.
If you're thinking you might
not have to mess with them,
don't start there.
You're going to
waste a lot of time.
I don't think I'm going
to have to deal with them.
And in fact, I'm only
going to need four.
I'm going to find four equations
involving F1, F2, x, and theta.
OK.
So here's how I'm saving
a little time today.
I've written it down for
you and I've written it out.
Same thing on your paper.
Let's talk about the first one.
This is a sum of forces in
this capital X direction, which
is our inertial frame, X,
on the main cart on mass 1.
So it's got to be the mass
times the acceleration.
And this is not [INAUDIBLE].
I don't how that
sneaked in there.
And I've called it-- in
capital, I had direction.
OK?
Mass times acceleration.
I just sum up all the
forces on the cart.
Spring force holds back.
The direction of the arrow
on my free body diagram
tells you the sense of it.
Minus KX minus bx dot
plus F2 cosine theta
plus F1 sine theta, all
in the X I hat direction.
OK?
Some of the forces on my little
bar here in the x1 direction.
Now x1 is down here.
And y1 is off that way.
So sum of the forces in
x1, which is now on mass 2,
must its mass times
its acceleration.
And I've just called it-- it
doesn't matter where I do my--
what point I'm
going to do angular
momentum with respect to.
This is Newton's law.
And it's the acceleration
of the center
of the gravity with respect
to an inertial frame.
But this is in the
little i hat direction.
So it's the complement
in that direction.
I have a minus F1i
And I have a plus M2g cosine
theta i in the i hat direction.
Pretty straightforward
Newton's second law.
Again, the other
component for Newton's
in the Y1 direction, mass times
the acceleration in the j hat
direction, minus F2j--
because my F2 happens
to be in the minus
direction in the free body
diagram-- minus M2g
sine theta in the j hat.
And finally, I'm going
to sum my moments
about the center of mass.
It would also work--
if I did it around A,
I would-- the reason you
normally do it around A, which
is why I started there, is why?
What's the advantage
of doing it around A?
The potential advantage
of going to A?
AUDIENCE: So you can
eliminate forces at the pin.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
F1 and F2 don't generate
moments at the pin.
And there's a hope
that, then, you
can get what you need
to know without ever
having to evaluate F1 and F2.
Right?
And in this case, they're going
to pop up in these equations.
And you're going to have to deal
with them anyway, it turns out.
So it doesn't actually give
you much of an advantage.
So it's easier because
the torque equation's
easier in terms of the
number of terms it has.
That's what makes it slightly
easier in this problem.
You've got to deal
with F1 and F2 anyway.
So it's just the time rate
of change of the angular
momentum with respect to g.
And that's external torques.
And the only external
torque is caused by F2.
And I left out a minus sign.
You have it on your
paper, I think, here.
No, it's correct.
It's positive.
So you have, F2 acts on
a moment arm about g, L2.
And it's going to be
in the k hat direction.
That's the external
torque on the system.
Its gravity causes no torque
because it's acting at g.
All right?
And this has got to be the
time rate of change of h.
I claim in this
problem-- you don't
have to do this--
but in this problem,
I claim I can write h as
a mass moment of inertia
matrix times a vector that tells
you what the rotation rate is.
You, in fact, can
always do this about g.
This is I with respect to g.
If you know what
it is, this I-- I
have chosen a set of
coordinates that pass
through the center of mass.
x1 that way, y1 perpendicular to
it, are they principal coord--
and z coming out of the board--
are they principal coordinates?
Sure, you know that.
This is just a uniform rod.
But just symmetry, immediately,
should tell you that they are.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I thought you said
that IMA could only work
for a stationary rotation axis.
I thought IMA could only
work for a stationary axis
of rotation.
PROFESSOR: And rotation
about the center of mass.
You can always do things
with the center of mass.
OK?
But you could just work this
out by the basic definition
of angular momentum.
Don't do it the hard way,
r cross p's and those kind
of things.
And you end up in
the same place.
This one, because
it's 0 0 omega z,
when you do the multiplication,
this is a diagonal.
The only term that
matters is this one.
Right?
So that's going to give us an
IzzG theta double dot, which
is omega z, k hat direction.
And it's not theta double dot.
The h gives you theta dot.
Omega z is theta dot.
And we've taken the
time derivative,
which gets us theta double dot.
And we know what the
mass moment of inertia
about a uniform
stick is with respect
to G, ML squared over 12.
Theta dot-- OK.
So there's our four equations
that we have to work with.
And do they involve N1 or N2?
Not at all.
That's why I said we
had, potentially, six.
We really only
have four unknowns.
And now you use these two
to solve for F1 and F2.
And once you get
expressions for F1 and F2
you can eliminate them
from here and here.
And you're done.
But there's a bit of
work left to do that.
But that's the approach.
You use these two
to isolate F1 and F2
and plug them into
these two to get
your final equations of motion.
But we have a couple of
things we don't know yet
that we need in here, the
acceleration of that center
of mass in the i hat--
and break into two
components, i hat and j hat.
But that's what we've been
studying kinematics for.
So we need to know the velocity
of G with respect to O.
And we need to know
the acceleration of G
with respect to O. OK?
So the velocity is
pretty straightforward.
We've done this many times.
So the velocity of
A with respect--
Remember, you pick things
you know to work from.
And you try to make as few as
possible things you don't know.
Or put them in
forms that we know
how to go about getting it.
These are vectors.
Do we know the velocity
of A with respect to O?
What's A?
A is the place where the pin is.
What's its velocity
at that point?
AUDIENCE: x dot.
PROFESSOR: x dot.
And in what direction?
AUDIENCE: Capital I hat.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So this is x dot capital I hat.
And now this term, the velocity
of G with respect to A,
this is a rigid body which
is rotating and translating.
And we've run into
this before, right?
And basically, the
equation for such things
is the motion of the
translational velocity
of the object plus the
velocities within the object,
including anything
contributed by rotation.
So this term is the velocity of
the point G, with respect to A,
to the center-- velocity of
the center G with respect
to point A.
And that is-- I'll write
it consistently here.
This is the velocity of G
with respect to A evaluated
if you had no rotation.
If you're sitting--
the other way
the books often
say it is this is
what you would see if you were
on the object sitting at A
looking and G. Is it moving?
You'd say no.
Well, another way of
saying that, that's
the velocity of this thing
if there were no rotation.
All right?
So this term happens to be 0.
Plus omega-- now we're kind
of doing this on purpose.
We know this is omega
z in the k direction.
But reminding you,
make it always
with respect to the
inertial frame-- cross
RGA, the position vector
from between the two points.
And so this case,
we end up with an x
dot I hat plus-- this is going
to be-- omega zk cross L/2
little i hat.
k cross i is j.
So x dot I hat.
This is in the little j moving
coordinate system direction.
Omega z is theta dot.
Theta dot L over 2 j hat.
I didn't even leave
enough room here.
Let me see this.
x dot I plus.
OK?
Familiar, our omega term.
So that's your velocity
of G with respect to O.
We need to find an acceleration
of that same point.
And we're going to take the
derivative of this to get it.
A point to-- we haven't
talked about this in a while.
This has mixed unit vectors.
Right?
It's got unit vectors in the
inertial frame and the unit
vectors in the rotating frame.
Is that allowed?
No problem.
It's perfectly
legitimate, right?
You have to reduce
it, eventually,
to get a workable equation.
But that's just fine at
this intermediate stage.
OK.
The next thing you want to do
is find this a with respect
to G-- aG with respect
to O, the acceleration.
And we know that's just
a derivative, remember,
with respect to the
inertial frame-- that's
why we have to deal with this
rotation business-- of velocity
of G with respect to O. But
the derivative of this-- does I
change direction?
Nope.
So this is just x double dot.
And we have a single
term here that we
have to take a derivative of.
So we get a theta
double dot L/2 j.
This is a little lowercase j.
But now, does j rotate?
Yeah?
And so this is the derivative
of a rotating vector.
The derivative of j
is minus theta dot I.
So minus theta dot
squared L over 2 i hat.
All right?
And that's all there
is to getting G.
Now we could have done--
oops, I want that one.
I don't want you to be afraid
of using the big, kind of hairy
looking 3D vector
equation for acceleration.
Acceleration and this gets
called-- this is A with respect
to O, putting it in
terms of this problem,
plus the acceleration
of G with respect
to A evaluated with no rotation
plus omega dot cross RGA
plus omega cross omega
cross RGA plus 2 omega cross
velocity GA omega equals 0.
And I should have one, two,
three, four, five terms.
There's always five
potential terms
when you're evaluating the
acceleration of a point
on a rigid body which is
translating and rotating.
This is translating and
rotating reference frames,
attached to the rigid body.
And then you just go
in and fill it in.
This is the acceleration
of the rigid body,
the translational acceleration.
In this problem, what is that?
Louder.
AUDIENCE: X double dot.
PROFESSOR: OK.
This guy is capital
X double dot I hat.
All right?
This is the acceleration
of point G relative to A
if you were in the
object, on the object.
It is?
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: All right.
0.
This is the Eulerian term.
This is theta double dot
crossed with the distance
from between the two points.
Is this 0?
No, not necessarily.
So this is theta double dot.
This is the L/2.
That's this.
And when you do the cross
product of k and I, you get j.
That's that term.
Omega cross omega cross RGA,
this is the centripetal term.
Would you think
it's going to be 0?
Nope.
So this is k cross I.
That's j. k cross j is
I minus-- this is the term
that gives you minus-- theta
dot squared L/2 i.
And this is our Coriolis term.
It requires motion of that
point, G, relative to A.
Is that moving?
Nope.
So this term just goes to 0.
Get the same answer?
All right.
So don't be afraid of this.
This thing, just lay it down.
Just plug the things in and
the right things will fall out.
All right.
On the paper, I break down the
acceleration of G with respect
to O into its little i
and little j components.
And I end up with
acceleration of G with respect
to O. I group the terms.
The I capital X double
dot sine theta--
I actually have to
break this-- see,
this is not in the direction
of little i or little j.
So I know that I can express
capital I as a lowercase i sine
theta plus j cosine theta.
And I use that.
So it's X double dot
sine theta minus L/2
theta dot squared-- it is in
the little i hat direction.
So this is the i hat term--
plus X double dot cosine theta
plus L/2 theta double dot.
And this is the j hat term.
OK?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Why would you choose
to put everything in terms
of the rotating inertial frame?
PROFESSOR: You
have to always have
these same decisions to make.
And it's what you're
comfortable with,
what you think is going
to lead to the least work.
You have no idea how much time
I spent working on this problem
to put it in a
form that I thought
I could teach it to you.
I spent a lot of time on it, the
point being, occasionally, you
have to spend a lot of time
working them out, going down
a path that doesn't pay
off, backing up, going down
the next one.
On quizzes, on
homework, most of what
stops you from getting
to the final right answer
is confidence.
You've got to
believe that you've
learned these things
well enough that you know
this is the right thing to do.
And it'll get you there if you
just do the arithmetic right.
OK?
And we all make little mistakes.
And you'll all have to
back up and do it again.
But that's why the
fundamentals and understanding
the basic concepts
are so important.
If you've got the
concepts down cold,
you'll have confidence that
your method's going to work.
OK.
So this is my i direction term.
This is my j direction term.
I can take those and take
this bit and plug it in here.
Let's just give it a name.
Let's call this A and
this piece here B.
And your A goes right here.
That's A. And this is B. OK?
And not that you've
made that substitution,
you can solve for F1.
And they're all in
one direction now.
They're all in the
little i hat direction.
You make the other substitution,
everything's in little j hat.
And you can drop them.
You no longer have
to carry it along.
You now have scalar equations
you can solve for F1 and F2.
So that's done.
And you take those
two expressions--
so this implies F1 equals-- and
this one implies F2 equals--
and you take those.
And you put F1 and F2--
you need F1 and F2.
And you plug it in here.
And in this equation,
you only need an F2.
And when you do that, you get
your two equations of motion.
Now a couple things happen.
It turns out, when
you do this-- when
you make the substitution in
here-- you end up with an MX
double dot cosine squared theta
and an M2 X double dot sine
squared theta.
And sine squared
plus cosine squared
conveniently equals-- 1.
And that collapses
and goes away.
So you end up with the
two final expressions
here after you've made
those combinations.
So from four over here--
I'll call it four prime--
you get one of your
equations of motion.
That's one equation of motion.
It's primarily about
the translation of-- I
mean rotation-- of the system.
It derives from all those
substitutions in this equation.
Curiously, these two
bits go together,
which, if you had worked
around A and you used,
dangerously, perhaps, a
parallel axis theorem,
you would have ended up
with ML squared over 3.
But that's your
first equa-- that's
one of your equations of motion.
And from the first one, it
comes from the sum of the forces
on the main mass, M1,
plus M2 X double dot
plus b X dot plus KX.
All the usual, just things
for mass spring oscillator.
But now you've got
these additional forces
that are exerted on that
because it's got this pendulum
flagging back and forth.
And if I made a mistake on
the board, believe the paper.
I think I've got it
all transcribed right.
This is your force
equation on the main mass.
If you didn't have the
pendulum hanging there,
there's your equation of
motion for a cart going
back and forth with springs.
Then you have this pendulum
hanging on it, which
puts additional forces on it.
It comes through
those F1 and F2 terms.
And you can see they have to
do with having to accelerate
things down there.
OK?
Now these two
equations are actually
quite easy to linearize.
So linearize means
you can always
linearize around the
equilibrium position.
This is its
Small motions.
That can be described,
what you see there,
by linearized
equations of motion.
And to linearize-- so for
theta small sine theta
is approximately equal to theta.
Cosine theta is
approximately equal to 1.
And you just have sines
and cosines in here.
You let this guy go to 1.
You let this go to theta.
Here, 1.
Here, theta.
And you have linearized
equations of motion.
Now other problems can
be harder to linearize.
But this is particularly simple.
Two linear equations, solvable.
If you solve them,
they'll give you
two natural frequencies for the
system and two vibration modes.
All right.
That's the end of this problem.
Any last questions about it?
I'm going to move on to this
topic of center percussion.
OK.
This next one is kind of fun.
It has a real practical
purpose in life.
I didn't bring my tennis
racket or my baseball bat.
But if any of you
play sports that
use things that hit things,
you know, when hit the baseball
and you hit it
down on the handle,
it really stings your hands.
Right?
Or the tennis racket, if
you don't hit it right,
you feel a lot of
forces in your hands.
And you hit it really sweet,
you feel almost no force at all.
How many have had
that experience?
Really common.
OK.
So is there a right
place to hit it?
The answer's yes.
And we're going to go
through that right now.
So here's our--
I'm looking down.
Here's my baseball bat.
z is in this direction.
This is kind of the top view.
So here's my handle of my bat.
Ball's coming in.
Put some force on it.
I think I put it
lowercase in the notes.
OK?
And I want to know-- and I
want to minimize that force
at my hands.
I'm going to call
this place where
it hits P. I'm going to say
here's its center of mass at G.
The point about which
you're holding it
and it's rotating is A. And
my coordinate system attached
to the bat-- we always have
this coordinate system attached
to the bad in these
rotational problems
so that we can divine things
like moments of inertia.
So it's a coordinate
system attached to the bat.
And here's my y direction.
And z's coming out of the board.
And this distance is going
to be important to me, RGA.
And this distance here,
I'm going to call q.
It's my unknown.
And I want to know,
where's the sweet spot.
What do I want q to be so that
I minimize the force at A,
where I'm hanging onto it.
So how many degrees of freedom?
How many independent coordinates
do I need to do this problem?
This problem is complicated,
because it's a-- you know,
a real life situation
is probably complicated.
And I'm going to do a lot
of simplification and claim
that the answer-- and
then look at the answer
and say, does it makes sense.
Did my simplifications
make sense?
So I'm going to do a
number of simplifications.
I'm going to argue that I think
I can get at most of the answer
by essentially saying, right
here where I'm hitting it,
my wrists are like
a hinge point.
That's point A. I'm going to
assume it rotates about a fixed
point at that moment.
OK?
Pretty gross simplification
of the real thing going on.
You've really got muscles,
you're putting moments on it,
your wrists actually
are moving some.
But I'm just going to say
rotating only about that point.
It stays in this plane.
It's a planar motion problem.
At most, three possible
degrees of freedom,
x, y, and some theta.
Right?
And I'm going to make
the simplification
that it's pinned at A.
So if it's pinned at A, how
many constraints is that?
AUDIENCE: Two.
PROFESSOR: Two.
One left.
So I only need-- I'm going
to pick one coordinate.
That's going to be my theta.
So even though I've made
these gross simplifications,
will the answer actually
turn out to be meaningful?
And this G is my center of mass.
And let's assume that
we know Izz with respect
to G, that is, mass moment
of inertia for rotation in z.
OK?
Assume that we know that.
It's given.
So for this problem,
when you have fixed
rotation points--
this problem here,
that A point wasn't fixed.
It was moving, accelerating.
It could have had lots
of complicated terms
in its expression for torque
if you'd done it that way.
This is fixed at A. It
makes a lot of sense
to compute moments
about A. All right?
So my first equation
here, that I
want, is the sum of the moments,
torques with respect to A.
And these are-- well,
they will all turn out
to be in the z direction here.
And they are time rated
change of the angular momentum
with respect to G, which, in
these planar motion problems,
always then boils down to
the mass moment of inertia
for the axis you're rotating
it about times the angular
acceleration.
That's that term.
Oops, not G. A.
Excuse me.
We picked our point.
We've got to stick with it here.
OK.
I need that.
And this is in the
k hat direction.
This is the only term
in our torque equation.
What are the external torques?
Well now, z is out of
the board like this.
I've got a force
acting on a moment arm
giving me a torque in
the other direction.
So this is minus
fq-- also k hat.
Now I might have
done this sooner,
but we should look at
a free body diagram.
So here's a little
stick figure of my bat.
And I potentially
have an unknown force
in the y direction, Ry,
and another unknown force
in the x direction here
at A, that pin point
where it's rotating it about.
Out here is G.
And at G, is there an mG term?
Well, it's gravity, right?
But it's acting-- it's
in the minus z direction.
And I'm looking down on it.
This is a top view.
So gravity would create a
moment in the y direction.
And I don't have
to deal with that.
My only moment-- this
is my torque equation--
only has k hat terms in it.
Gravity creates a
moment in the y,
which, in fact, you have to--
that's a static equilibrium
problem-- you do have
to provide that when
you're holding the bat or
else the bat would droop.
Right?
It doesn't have anything to do
with the dynamics, actually.
OK.
Here's G. There's no gravity
term that you can see.
It's pointing into the board.
And out here is my
point P. And here's f.
OK.
So I need an equation-- I
have an equation for moment
equilibrium.
I need some dynamic equation.
I have two possible equations
for force equilibrium.
How many unknowns do I have?
But no others.
Three possible unknowns.
I'm going to need
three equations
to get rid of these two terms.
Right?
And I am looking ahead.
My objective is to
make that term go to 0.
So I both have to find
an expression for it
and then figure out
how to make it go to 0.
That's how you do this problem.
OK.
So let's do sum of
the forces in the y.
So you have an Ry j hat minus
f, also in the j hat direction.
And that's basically
all there is to that.
But that must be
the mass of the bat
times the acceleration
of G with respect
to O in the y direction.
So that's our j hat component.
This is just the component
of acceleration in the j hat
direction.
And the sum of the forces
in x, we look at those.
Well, we have an Rx in the i.
And there are no others.
And that must be, then,
the mass of the bat
times the acceleration, G,
with respect to O, of the bit
in the x direction.
And that'll be in the i hat.
So I've got two unknown
accelerations, now,
that I have to deal with.
But we know lots
of kinematics now.
So let's do it this way just
to give you the practice.
Acceleration of G with respect
to O. Acceleration of A
with respect to O plus the
acceleration of G with respect
A omega equals 0 plus omega
dot cross RGA plus 2 omega
cross VGA omega equals 0,
and finally, plus omega
cross omega cross RGA.
One, two, three,
four, five terms.
Our vector 3D equation
is figured out quickly.
What's this term?
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: 0?
Why?
AUDIENCE: It's fixed.
PROFESSOR: Fixed
point of rotation,
that's our assumption.
This guy goes to 0.
OK.
The velocity of G
with respect to A?
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Another 0.
Omega dot cross RGA?
So that could-- you
know, if there's
an angular acceleration,
which there might be,
cross R, that's a
perfectly legitimate term.
And that'll give you
a-- this will give you
a theta double dot, just before.
It's in the k direction,
cross RGA in the i.
That's this term right here.
OK.
This velocity of G
with respect to A
on the bat, that went to 0.
The Coriolis, that goes away.
So at this point, I've only
got one term from there.
And this term is our
centripetal term.
You think there's going
to be a centripetal force?
Common sense should be any time
you have a rotational moment,
something rotating about a
point, if the center of mass
is not the point
of rotation, you
will be forcing a mass
to move in a circle.
And that always requires--
that centripetal acceleration--
always requires a force.
This, for sure,
will give you a term
which is a minus omega z squared
type term times the distance
RGA.
That's its radius.
And it's inward.
So in this direction,
it will be i hat.
Three terms, same as before.
We now have our accelerations.
OK.
So from our top
equation up there
from the summation
of forces in the y,
we'll now substitute these in.
We have M RGA j hat.
The acceleration term, we ended
up with the-- the k cross i
term gives you j.
So the Eulerian term is
going to show up here.
So that, we need a
theta double dot.
And this is in the j direction.
That comes from the
acceleration we figured out.
And that's equal
to minus f plus Ry.
And this is all little j hat.
Let me write the
other one first here.
Here's the summation
in the x direction.
It's mass times our acceleration
in the i hat direction.
And we only ended up
with one term doing that,
and that's our centripetal term.
So we get minus RGA
theta dot squared i hat.
That's the centripetal
acceleration times the mass.
And the only term
that it is equated to
is the other reaction force.
OK?
So here's the key
step in this problem.
We want what to
be 0 so that we're
hitting it at the sweet spot?
What's the original objective?
We want Ry to go away.
All right?
Just make it go away.
So f, then-- I'll do it
as an intermediate step.
Just a second. f is then--
I'm going to leave Ry
for just a second longer.
Ry minus M RGA theta double dot.
And since this is my--
I can drop the j hats.
This is now a scalar equation.
I can find an expression
for this force
that-- I don't even
know what the force is
that the ball exerts on the bat.
But it exists.
I can say this must be true.
And my objective is
that this should be 0.
So that says, when
that's true, f
is minus M RGA theta double dot.
And I'm going to use
that in just a moment.
So I'm going to substitute
this into our first equation
up there for moment,
equation number one.
So this implies that f is
minus M RG with respect
to A theta double dot.
And this goes into 1,
which I have in fq.
So I do that.
Where are my notes?
This is now also
a scalar equation.
I can drop the k hats.
So Izz with respect to A theta
double dot equals minus fq.
But f is minus, so
the minuses cancel.
So I get M RGA theta
double dot times q.
Now Izz with respect to A can be
expressed as M times some thing
we call the radius of gyration
squared with respect--
and this has got to
be-- with respect to A.
The radius of gyration
for rotation about A,
I can find an
expression like this
so that it's equal to
Izz with respect to A.
And all the radius
of gyration means
is that if I took all the mass
and put it that distance away,
the mass moment of inertia
of that concentrated point
mass with respect to
the point of rotation
is the same as in
the real object.
So this is just a
convenience that we use.
So that's M Kappa squared.
And that says, then, that M
Kappa squared A equals M RGA
theta double dot-- I have a
theta double dot here too.
Sorry-- times q.
And I can solve for q.
The theta double dots go away.
The M's go away.
And q is just Kappa
squared A divided by RGA.
And that's the answer to this
center of percussion problem.
Here's your bat.
Here's A. Here's G. Here's
P. The q is about here.
Whoops, excuse me.
q is the distance
to P. It's always
outside of G. It will
always be outside of G.
We'll have to think about,
maybe, the reason for that.
So here's the center of mass.
Here's RGA.
and here's this
point at which you
want to hit at the sweet spot.
And it's always Kappa
squared A over RGA.
Now how do you get
to Kappa squared A?
Well, you need to evaluate
Izz with respect to A.
But Izz with respect to A, you
can do parallel axis theorem,
Izz with respect with respect
to G plus M RGA squared.
Right?
And then you have that.
So if we were to do this--
I'll give you a quick example.
If this were a uniform rod, Izz
G equals ML squared over 12.
Izz with respect to A ML
squared over 12 plus MRG
with respect to A squared.
That is ML squared over
12 plus ML squared--
this is L/2 to RGA,
half the length,
if I put A right at the end.
So I'm doing the simple rod.
I'm putting A right here,
G right in the middle.
So this is L/2-- ML
squared over 2 squared, 4.
You add those two together,
you get ML squared over 3
equals M Kappa A squared.
So Kappa squared A
is L squared over 3.
And q equals L squared
over 3 divided by L/2.
So you get 2/3 L. 2/3 of the
length puts you out here.
Or at 1/2 the length--
so here's L/2.
Here's P at 2L/3.
So anytime you run into these
center of percussion problems--
tennis racquet, baseball bats,
whatever-- the right place
to hit it is away from
the point of rotation.
Now do you think this is--
now how good is this model?
You know, you start
thinking about, well,
what are the things-- if the
bat handles really moving.
It's still actually
remarkably good.
It's remarkably good.
In fact, the fact
these other things
are happening,
like you're putting
some moment on with your
wrists, the fact that you still
have some speed down
here, all you're doing
is kind of maybe changing the
point it's rotating around.
But you're still having to
exert forces with your hands
at that point where
you're holding it.
And you just want those
forces to go to 0.
All of these other
complications,
you're still going to find out,
to make that force go to 0,
it's approximately that.
Really a pretty good answer.
All right.
Ah, let's go back.
And we have another
piece of information
that we developed in this
problem that we haven't used.
We had another equation.
We had the acceleration
in the i direction.
And it's just equal to RX.
The RX force is M times
the acceleration in the i
direction.
And that's minus RG with
respect to A theta dot squared.
That's our old centripetal
force term, right?
Centrifugal force,
centripetal acceleration.
Here's the centripetal
acceleration times
the mass is the force to make
the bat go in the circle.
You have to provide that force.
OK?
So I want to finish
up by a loose end
that many people have--
continue to have--
a little trouble with.
Because I get questions
on Muddy cards about this.
And it was on this
last homework.
I don't know how that wheel
with the little bit missing--
if you all got that sorted out.
If you're all perfectly clear
in your mind about that then
I don't need to
say what I'm going
to talk about for a second.
But I thought I
would just tie that
up, the last little bit here.
This problem is a
nice lead to it.
This last force
that I computed is
the force required to swing
this thing in a circle.
And I'm putting that
force right here.
And I'm saying it's-- actually
the point of rotation is right
here.
And that force is the mass times
the acceleration of that point.
And that point is a distance
from my point of rotation
to the center of mass.
No accident.
You're accelerating
the center of mass.
That times the
rotation rate squared
is the acceleration, the
centripetal acceleration.
This is the force.
So any time you have an
object-- maybe it's a wheel,
and maybe it has, stuck
on it, a little extra mass
you don't know about, a
rock stuck in your tire.
This is the center of rotation.
Your axle on your
wheel doesn't move.
Tire doesn't move
relative to the axle.
You've got this little
bit of mass missing
or added, doesn't much matter.
The center of mass
of this system
is no longer at the
center of rotation.
So I'll call the center
of rotation here A.
That's what it's rotating about.
This addition or loss
of a piece of mass
makes the center of mass of
the system move a little bit.
So I have an extra little
bit of mass out here.
The new actual center
gravity of this system
is a little distance away.
And I'll call that
distance e, eccentricity.
So now I have a system
whose center of mass
is not at the
center of rotation.
And its distance, RGA, I'm
calling the eccentricity.
And as this rotates-- and
I'll put a coordinate system
on here.
i, x, y, rotating
with the system.
The force, it's going to
appear here on this axle.
It's going to have a
force that I'll call Rx.
Rx equals the mass times the
acceleration of the center
of gravity of the system.
And the acceleration
of the center
of gravity in this system is
minus e theta dot squared.
And it's inward in
the i hat direction.
Therefore, the minus sign.
So the force-- this is the
centripetal acceleration
times mass-- the force
required to make it
do that is an inward force minus
M e theta dot squared i hat.
OK?
I drew Rx in a
positive direction.
The answer comes out minus.
It says it's going
the other way.
So this is always the case.
If you have a system
that, for some reason,
does not rotate about
its true center of mass,
but in fact the center of mass
is off a little bit or a lot,
you will have to provide
a force that's inwardly
directed as that thing spins.
OK?
Now a subtlety I want you to
know, to really go away with,
is that we've talked quite
a lot about unbalance
due to these masses
that aren't concentrated
at the center, these
unbalanced masses.
There are two kinds of
unbalance the engineers have
chosen to describe the
world with, two kinds.
One is static imbalance and
the other is dynamic imbalance.
A statically imbalanced
system is one in which you--
I'm looking at a side view
of-- an edge view of this thing
as it's spinning,
maybe like this.
And the center of
rotation is here.
And the G is here.
That force is inward on it.
But really, it's
perfectly symmetric.
So this force that
I'm having to provide
to keep this thing
from flying off
is perfectly inward directed.
Does it generate any
moments about this point?
None.
This is called static imbalance.
And here's an example
of static imbalance.
This is my rotor.
I'm going to put it on its side.
Gravity says, I want
this to hang down.
Because where's the center
of mass of this system?
Up here?
Along here?
It's down here somewhere, right?
That center of mass, you do a
statics calculation, MG sine
theta, it's going to hang down.
So that's why they call
it static imbalance.
And the way you can correct a
statically imbalanced system
is just do the test.
Put the thing-- hang
the thing on an axle.
And do I have a handy
axle here today?
Put it on an axle and
see if it rotates.
And if it always rotates
to some point hanging down,
you know this thing's
statically imbalanced.
Look in my kit of parts here.
Just maybe do this.
I don't know if this is
heavy enough to do the job.
But now I've put a little
bit of mass on here.
And I presume that if I do
this with it, OK, it goes down.
This system is
statically imbalanced.
This system, now, is also
dynamically imbalanced.
Why?
It kind of depends on
where I do the calculation.
But if I say that I
want to know-- this
is when put a force, a
mass, off-center here.
And if I compute moments about a
point that's perfectly lined up
with it, this system will create
no moments about that point.
This system is
perfectly balanced now.
The mass that I've
stuck on here is there.
This system is
perfectly balanced.
It generates no
moments as it stands,
no matter where you
calculate this point.
But this extra
little bit-- this is
A. If I compute H
with respect to A
here and do the
derivatives of it,
I get no torques except
in the z direction.
But as soon as I
move away from there,
and there is a distance
here, and I compute moments
about that, do I get
some static moments
not in the direction of spin?
Yes.
So when you do that, this
system-- if this is my point A,
let's call it, over
here-- this system,
is it statically imbalanced?
Yep.
Is it dynamically imbalanced?
Yeah.
So how would you balance it?
Final question of
the term for me.
How would you put this
system into balance?
AUDIENCE: Put another
mass on the other side.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So if I put another mass
here, will that statically
balance it?
Statically balance,
meaning if I let go,
will it have to rotate
around and find a low point.
Is there any low
point-- if I put
one equal and opposite, equal
distance away, opposite side,
would it be statically balanced?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, because
gravity pulls down on this one,
equal and opposite
down on this one.
So it would be
statically balanced.
Would it be
dynamically balanced?
The system, as you spin,
will try to twist like this.
So it's not
dynamically balanced.
What if I move it over here?
Is it statically balanced?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Is it
dynamically balanced?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Hmm.
Compute the torques.
You know?
Let's put A right in the center,
compute the angular momentum,
take its time
derivative, and you
will find that this
one, as it spins,
tries to create a
moment like that.
And this one, as it spins tries
to create a moment like that.
And they're exactly
equal and opposite.
This is dynamically balanced
and statically balanced.
Hmm.
AUDIENCE: When there
was just one mass,
was it dynamically balanced
about A, the axis of rotation.
PROFESSOR: This is
not dynamic-- if you
put A right in the usual
center-- the original center
of gravity, we'll call A, at
this wheel-- this system is not
dynamically balanced with
respect to an A that's
right on the axle
and on the center.
Because it has
this little offset.
OK?